At the beginning of this legislature, the
Socialists and Democrats
committed to working for the climate
with specific legislation to
ensure that we undertake the
transition towards a more
sustainable model for the environment but
also for people,
we recently reached an agreement on the law
and today the commission has finally
presented the first set of laws
to achieve the objectives that we
have set for ourselves, which must be contributed by
industry, transport, all
sectors and citizens, as
we requested, there will be a fund to help
make this a  fair transition and that
no one is left behind but we socialists will
propose to provide it with more
financing we will be vigilant so
that the fiscal reform rewards
those who are committed to that
just transition the
recovery plans are an opportunity to
invest in a more sustainable and
fairer future with  renovation of buildings
and investment in clean transport
t  We have a lot of work between now and the end
of the year, but we socialists are going to
fulfill our commitment to
people and the environment